ブーブーってにょ作ろうやっおっ
[音楽]
フィギュアゲームずこれを永らえる叱るということですね
車中の作り方だと専用のケースがありますこのケースに窯をこうやってセットしてこう
いう感じで壁てってこの中に好きなパウダーを入れて水を入れたコップに入れて
ひっくり返して水を切ったら出来上がりという何なんですけどもう
私はどんな誠しないぞなぜなら私はスーパーフォール初めてどんな形のことを私はし
ないで
a 本堂が生徒が間違われるな本当にこれから説明書何もないんでこれけど簡単なん
ですよ
徐々にこれ水に漬けたらスーパーボウルになるっていうものらしいのでひとまずこの
パンダー全部を何か手詰なければいけの音で今回このスーパー
俺の粉を入れケースの代わりにないがないかと思ったところ
わー
やってもうたこれは俳句前しかないなと思いましたこの船を使って風船ですクラウンで
なるべくこの中に粉を入れてこんなの中でこの光るスーパーボウルや rom を入れ
て今日
期間巨大スーパーボールを作ってみようと思いますまずこれを膨らませなきゃいけない
やりますはどこまで ed x かっていうのがポイントですねうわぁこれ厳しい戦い
になりそうだな明日もぜひ入るああああ胃痛光ってますな
ブーブーは完全に player ぱこれ厳しくねこれはもう day by 2パ
ティっおっちらああああっ
作成変更風船はちょっと難しそうなスーパーの袋でありましょう
普通にこうするともあるじゃないんですけど両端を押さえればマルっぽくなるんでそれ
でいいのか夏黒猫ドイルネット収容所もらおう
いやああああっっっは
me
よっしゃい全部入りました1回混ぜましょうか
おおいい感じじゃないでしょうか結構きれいに混ざりましたねこのままやってもきれい
な丸にならないので光る坊ちゃんと入れないといけばずこれだけ言うときますね
埋め込めばいいんだよなかねあとはこれの形を整えてちゃんとボールにあるようにし
ます冷めてる紙テープ問題でよってまずボールの片付いて晴れてればすればボールなん
でシェーパーボールっぽい形に
上がれば ok だ木はしておりますしか着けたい
科学的にはかなりバルに2ついたのでここでポイントなんですけども多分このままつけ
てもできないんですよなんだこれ水に浸すかといいますとこれよく見たら微妙に音穴が
開いてるんですよたぶんこの穴から水が入ってきて固まってスーパーボウルになるので
これまでちゃんと穴開けて水を通さないとスーパーボウルに
[音楽]
ブーバーあるねえ
水を切らなきゃいけないんだよもう切っちゃいます加えたかそういうしておいて方です
ねこんなものの5分では方程します散らせばされよ
[音楽]
ここからケースから取り出して約10分が本当して乾燥させてください
はあああええええええっ
[音楽]
ブーブー言っに感染しましたこちら大量の家創り
スーパーボウルで作った巨大な比較スーパーボールです悪くないですよ
イケますよこれ弾力はねすっげあるんですよこれ多分いきますよ
引っ張るかそして育ってここでここでただいたら例えたら光る
これ
他の部分はほかほかの部分は他の誰かが光ってほしい
すげー部分的無勉で綺麗ですけどちゃんと光っておりますそれじゃあもうちょっと
たくさん入れるはずなんだけどなんか
国算がこうここだけしかしからないねまあいいでしょ光っていることで変わりありませ
ん飲んだよくからですこれが本当にスーパーゴールとして跳ねるかどうか
[音楽]
ございました
[拍手]
uh
あああん
me
[音楽]
dea
me
ana ああああ